gorgeous picture there the scottish
highlands we've been reporting on the
high stakes u.n climate conference in
scotland where world leaders are working
to reduce greenhouse gases but carbon
dioxide the main culprit has also been
seeping into the air from some
surprising places like peat bogs that's
a type of wetland where it has been
contained harmlessly we should add for
thousands of years as part of our eye on
earth series mark phillips takes us now
into the scottish highlands to see
another battleground in the fight to
save the planet
it's always uphill on the way to work
yeah it seems so quite the
quite often stories about climate change
required trekking to some remote corner
of the planet
usually to discover the latest worrying
effect
but this climb up through the highlands
of scotland with conservationist sheila
rao is in search of a solution or at
least part of one
much of this landscape is covered in
soaking wet peat a kind of swamp of
vegetation that is decomposed over
thousands of years
and which given the weather up here
never dries out
in terms of fighting climate change
that's important we're standing on a big
carbon sink here this is we are carbon
that's in the ground and not in the air
exactly
peat it turns out is much better at
sequestering carbon than even trees peat
bogs make up just three percent of the
earth's land mass but store 30 percent
of all land-based carbon twice as much
as the world's forests
so what happens is the vegetation is
capturing carbon from the atmosphere but
the saturation of the water in the
ground and how wet it is doesn't allow
any carbon to be lost it's kind of
sealed up so over time more and more
carbon is is sequestered and stored in
this habitat and it stays in it yes
because it's not exposed to the air to
oxygen and can't yeah well it stays in
it until what we see here is happening
what we see here is happening is vast
areas of peat being lost some of it
because increased rainfall is washing it
away
some because people have been harvesting
peat from bogs for centuries to use as
fuel it'll burn if it's dried out
some because it can be collected and
used as fertilizer
and some because huge tracts of peat
wetlands have been drained around the
world to be used in agriculture
effectively we're standing in the middle
of the problem here this was once peaked
up to the top and now it's been eroded
into this gully is that the problem yeah
exactly that's it so
historically the people would have
filled this but that's all been eroded
away down the hill side really yeah
lately as the value of peat as a carbon
store has been recognized people are
trying to save it
a major scottish project is using
mechanical diggers to recover exposed
areas of bog with wet moss to keep the
peat under it from drying out and
blowing away
the gullies where the peat is washing
away are being made shallower and also
lined with moss to slow the water flow
down and hopefully stop the erosion
stuart brooks of the scottish national
trust will be trying to convince others
at the glasgow climate conference just
how important peat bog preservation is
we find peatlands wetlands and swamps um
all over the planet about 180 countries
uh so in america in north america in
south america in in the
in the in the tropics in in southeast
asia and and here in northern europe as
well
and a funny thing is happening to land
values up here in these highlands
we used to think countryside like this
was almost worthless nothing but
windswept bogland now though companies
are falling over themselves trying to
buy up chunks of it because it's so
valuable
companies like this scottish brewery
which is offsetting its carbon footprint
by buying up and restoring peatland for
carbon credit
there's a boom going on in soggy real
estate we made the decision to buy the
land and
because it really was about us kind of
taking full control of the process can
you sell non-sustainable beer these days
you know i think i think going forward
you won't be able to
saving the planet or trying to one
shovel full of moss at a time
for cbs mornings mark phillips in the
cairngorm mountains of scotland
all you want to know about peat bogs i
never thought about peat bog before i
had not as well yeah i learned a lot
right there there you go thank you mark
phillips